[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic
nous allons tenter de comprendre les
mécanismes mathématiques de la
relativité générale
pour ce faire nous allons construire
petit à petit tous les outils
mathématiques est essentielle à la
relativité générale pour éviter de
surcharger le contenu cette série sera
découpé en plusieurs parties dans
lesquelles nous allons façonné chaque
notion une à une et qui seront publiés
dans des vidéos indépendante les calculs
et équations seront montrées en espérant
que le tout reste abordable et intuitif
chaque vidéo commencera par une
explication théorique suivie d'un ou
plusieurs exemples concrets pour mettre
en application les concepts développés
dans cette série nous allons réinventer
chaque concept de a à z
et pour commencer il est donc important
de tout oublier de faire table rase sur
toutes les notions que l'on pense
connaître de partir de rien devant nous
une feuille de papier sur laquelle est
tracée une courbe
[Musique]
cette feuille de papier est une image
pour représenter la structure de notre
univers l'espace temps celui ci possède
quatre dimensions
mais dans cette image simplifier on ne
représentera que deux de ses dimensions
la courbe à la surface de la feuille
décrit un objet par exemple une pomme
cette courbe est ce qu'on appelle sa
ligne d'univers nous allons tenter
d'interpréter cette courbe pour
commencer on découpe la ligne d'univers
en deux petits intervalles réguliers à
partir d'un point quelconque que l'on
choisit on numérote ces intervalles 1 à
de cette façon on muni la courbe d'une
graduation qui nous permet de la
transformer en une série de points
consécutifs ces points seront
interprétés comme une trajectoire
la courbe n'est plus un objet mais un
mouvement
elle représente le mouvement de la pomme
dans l'espace temps on vient d'inventer
la notion de déplacement
on appellera ses graduation au cours
desquelles se déplace la pomme sont en
propre le temps propre de la pomme
correspond au temps qui rythment son
évolution interne en quelque sorte c'est
le temps qui s'écoulerait sur sa propre
horloge tandis qu'il augmente la pomme
évolue et se déplacent à travers les
dimensions de l'espace temps dans la
suite le temps propre sera désigné par
la lettre grecque d'eau
[Musique]
maintenant que la pomme se déplace sur
la feuille on désire décrire sa position
au fil du temps propres pour pouvoir
repérer un point de façon mathématique
on va munir notre feuille d'un système
de coordonnées
un tel système se présente comme une
grille que l'on trace sur la feuille
cette grille possède une origine 1.0 à
partir duquel on compte les cases une
par une
de cette façon la position de la pomme
sur la feuille va être décrite par deux
nombres qu'on appelle ses coordonnées il
est important de comprendre que cette
grille est arbitraire elle n'a pas de
sens physique
il s'agit simplement d'une convention
que l'on choisit un support abstrait
dont l'utilité est de décrire les points
par des nombres en fonction de la
situation que l'on analyse certes un
système de coordonnées seront plus
approprié que d'autres et nous aurons la
liberté d'utiliser celui qui nous
satisfait
[Musique]
illustrons tous ces concepts par un
exemple concret imaginons une pomme qui
tombe verticalement à la surface de la
terre et que nous observons depuis une
très grande distance en tant
qu'observateur distants intéressons nous
aux quantités que l'on peut mesurer
d'une part on peut mesurer la distance
qui sépare la pomme du centre de la
terre comme la chute de la pomme se fait
verticalement
cet unique distance permet de repérer la
position de la pomme sans ambiguïté
d'autre part on peut mesurer le temps
par rapport à notre horloge qui ne va
pas forcément s'écouler de la même façon
que le temps propre de la pomme de cette
façon on peut définir deux coordonnées
qu'on appellera t pour le temps et air
pour l'altitude qui permettent de
positionner la pomme dans l'espace temps
de façon relative à notre point de vue
alors que son temps propre c'est cool
la pomme va pouvoir se déplacer
librement et tracer sa trajectoire
à l'intérieur de ce système de
coordonnées attention il est important
de bien distinguer le temps tu es qui
est une coordonnée et le temps propre
taux qui représente quant à lui la
graduation sur la ligne d'univers
pour bien comprendre nos deux
coordonnées prenons un exemple si la
pomme passe par le point dont les
coordonnées sont une seconde et 7000 km
cela signifie que lorsque notre horloge
indique une seconde
on mesurera une distance de 7000 km
entre la pomme et le centre de la terre
dans l'espace temps il est important de
comprendre qu'aucun objet net immobile
en effet même s'il ne se déplace pas
dans l'espace comme une pomme qui
resterait immobile sur terre un corps va
quand même se déplacer dans le temps la
pomme avance chaque seconde vers notre
futur les objets ont donc tous une
vitesse dans l'espace temps et c'est
uniquement la répartition de cette
vitesse entre les différentes
coordonnées des espaces et de temps qui
va pouvoir varier
[Musique]